fifteen-year-old Suwabe is unusual in
Qatar because it's an ice hockey player
he's unique
in Casa because he's the first athlete
from the country ever to become a Winter
Olympian after qualifying for the 2020
Youth Olympic Games in Lausanne got only
seven cent Awards
I've been skating since I was seven
years old at this same rink I became
more fascinated by the game when I used
to watch ice hockey players from the
national team compete here I
participated in many competitions on an
international level and now I'm
competing for the games in Switzerland
after all the support I've received from
the league the coach and my team very
will compete in one of the games and
newest disciplines 3x3 ice hockey the
teams are formed of athletes from
different countries so the teenager will
be playing both with and against more
established nations like Sweden Finland
and the Czech Republic the introduction
of a new hockey format to the Winter
Games means the emerging nations don't
need an outstanding team they just need
an outstanding individual and that's
what Qatar has interwebz Barry
what they also have is a thriving
domestic competition the Qatar
International Ice Hockey League is
packed with experts from Canada and the
US as well as other countries playing
every week at a rink in one of many
shopping malls of the capital go Hawks
we have all kinds of levels we've got
guys who were once paid to play ice
hockey they're phenomenal players our
there's a rookie like myself
I've been Ricky for 4050 years and
there's about four or five countries
that are excellent skaters and they're
playing in our a division very
competitive it's amazing to watch these
kids boat and actually they're
challenging some of our a division
players now and quite honestly there's a
lot of those Qatari players who are way
better than me and very skilled after
the league introduced Qatar ease to the
sport the Olympic Committee wants to
take it further there's a nation
confident that they will become the
first of many to go from passing through
the food court to sports big estate
Sanaa Hamas al Jazeera Doha